该养孩子谁不知道有些钱是说不明白的，
谁不知道有些钱是算不明白账的呀，
并不是说你每一笔钱都要有证据，
只是说你要给法官一个依据，
这十二万八的彩礼花到哪里去了？
一般情况下生了孩子的彩礼都退不回去，
跟对方是分开来算，
不是完全分开的状态。
有的孩子现在是七个半月，
主要就是从三个方面吧，
一个方面是孩子的情况问题，
一个方面是我们现在感情家庭问题，
这个方面就是我们现在经济方面的问题。
现在孩子的话是去年6月底生了，
现在七个半月嘛，
9月中旬的时候，
也就不到三个月的时候，
被他爸爸偷偷带去了浙江那边，
后面我又在九月底的时候辞职，
刚上班半个月的工作，
就把东西搬到了老家，
又去了浙江带孩子，
我工作的期间呢，
他爸爸还有个情况，
就是在我们的车里面装了一个定位器，
这是我后面才知道的，
孩子子的话大概就是待在浙江他大姑家，
他奶奶待了十来天，
我去了之后就是我一直在带，
其实从孩子生到现在，
基本都是我一个人在带嘛，
我们在11月底的时候也跟他爸爸又经常的吵架，
住在他小姑家，
是和他奶奶，
他小姑他们一家以及他爸爸住在一起的，
我们就是经常吵架，
他就动不动就会说，
包括在之前也有过两三次，
但是没有证据，
在10月底的时候有监控视频，
那监控视频的话，
主要是小孩子看不器嘛，
有录音录像，
他说你带孩子走吧，
抚养权你要么就给我。
啊，
也不要争饲药钱，
就这种，
他已经多次说过这种话，
当时是小孩这个感冒的情况嘛，
他没有很多小孩空调开电费，
就是一晚上30多不能开口炉口啊，
七七八八就吵，
让小孩穿厚点，
就因为这些口头上会有一些争吵嘛，
后面我觉得说小孩感冒这个问题，
我不想跟他耗，
我就第二天打包的行李搬到了我爸妈上班那边去，
那我爸妈是不太清楚的，
是我到了之后才跟他们说的，
这是小孩的话，
到现在我是从12月自己租房在外面租了两个月，
但现在回了老家，
然后的话也可能是自己再去原来租房的那个地方，
我们是二四年初的时候，
家里亲戚介绍认识的，
3月份的时候就在一起，
9月份这些就订婚了，
然后10月份怀孕的，
在怀孕5个月的时候，
发现她在不同软件跟不同的女的聊天嘛，
当时的时候她也保证了就不会再聊，
后面等孩子生了之后就发现她在相亲软件上直接说自己离也了一个孩子，
我们是没有领证的，
已经分开什么的，
他就已经在和别人实用相亲认证，
这些是有视频录屏的，
但是这期间也就内耗了很久，
然后一直吵架把孩子带走的。
我们之间现在要谈的就是一个孩子抚养问题，
孩子他需要我要抚养权，
或者说让我退还权礼，
之前是主张存款权益，
以及呃，
不给孩子给他不要政抚养权，
但是我一直主张孩子是在我这边，
抚让权是给我的，
孩子现在户口已经算在我这边了，
我们名下有个车，
车是我这边贷款的，
在我名下是共同还。
贷款，
现在还有十几万的贷款，
你那个车也不值钱，
他要我过户给他彩礼是12.8个，
已经拿了一部分作为共同开支以及还贷了，
就是现在还剩下大概5个，
这样子的情况，
应该领证了吗？
样费没有，
没有领证啊，
这种情况下彩礼退不回去啊，
你就带着孩子好好过，
车在你名下也是你的财产，
你就带着孩子安心的过，
现在我主张分开，
因为他这种人因不方面原因已经不能继续供下去了嘛，
但是他现在又主张和好，
如果说我在法院起诉主张费害的话，
会不会在我这边你不需要起诉，
你为什么要起诉呢？
因为孩子先不着急，
你先这么过，
孩子抚养费就算你去起诉的话，
一个月可能就是千八百的钱，
顶什么用呢？
你先不着急，
因为孩子抚养费可以一把解决的，
现在你明确的跟他是分居了，
孩子明确的是你在干，
你想要抚养费的话，
你缓一缓，
不要为了这千八百的事情去激怒他，
因为他那头我告诉你，
他现在还有不甘，
还有愤怒，
还觉得亏，
还觉得给了你彩礼，
给了你车，
你牌子也不给我，
但是当他有了新的对象的时候，
他就释怀了，
他就不找你麻烦了，
但是现在他不管孩子，
他不会主动问孩子，
包括我发了之后，
他想和好，
他说他要管孩子的情况下是和好领证，
他得和好领证了他才会管孩子，
我自己是没有工作，
现在自己带孩子，
自己做的账号，
他那边清楚我做账号，
只是不知道我的收入情况，
他之前想和好的前提下。
我写了一个开支的明细，
意思就是说他现在5500的工资，
我们大概7000多的开支是基础的，
然后之意就是需要我拿钱，
那你想跟他结婚吗？
我不想，
那不想跟他结婚，
那现在我告诉你，
你该怎么做，
你就按照我说的这个节奏去做就完事儿了啊。
第一，
孩子呢，
既然在你身边，
孩子的所有的开支你都要留证据，
因为他给了你彩礼钱，
这个彩礼钱花到哪里去了，
得有个说道，
花到孩子身上的每一分钱都不存在退的问题，
包括在生孩子的过程当中的开销，
包括你自己的营养费，
吃饭这些的开销，
你都要拿得出证据来。
第二，
这个车在你名下，
就是你的东西，
现在负担不起车贷的话，
卖掉变成钱。
第三，
他那头说想要给孩子抚养费的话，
你就跟他说，
你说孩子啊，
奶粉钱多少钱，
尿不湿钱多少钱，
孩子多少钱，
一个月花多少钱，
每次你都跟他说，
孩子这个月又花了多少钱，
你想来看孩子，
你随时可以来看孩子，
你知道吧，
这个起到什么证据呢？
我告诉你孩子要花那么多钱呀，
你一次都没给过呀，
我向你主张过要孩子抚养费啊，
你都没给过呀，
我什么时候想去告你的话，
那法官他自己去判断啊，
该从什么时候开始算呢？
抚养费该从什么时候开始给呀，
就这意思，
嗯，
车的话，
他那边我提过说过户给他，
但是前天就给我2万，
因为我自己拿自己收的礼金也还债了。
再一个就产。
给还贷了，
但是他不同意，
他说把这个丢了都不会给我，
那就卖掉这个车，
因为车在你名下，
卖掉车钱也是在你名下，
孩子的话直接给他说过孩子花销怎么样的，
以因我现在也保留了孩子开销的小票之类的，
他之前是其倡了的我1500，
我不同意，
后面就变成了1000块钱，
所有的东西都不管，
医疗以及教育所有都不管，
一天随时想看就看，
我说那1000的话，
我干脆不要他的，
到现在就这么耗着玩，
我给他说的孩子情况他也没管，
那他才管，
你还想问我什么问题啊，
钱方面，
比如说我们现在彩里开销现在只剩5个嘛，
之前给他实际转账可能有快两个是吧，
如果说我要去理清楚这个孩子开销账单的话，
因为前两天我就想去把这个开支明细全部理清楚了，
但是不知道怎么去理，
就怎么证明。
以前没有票据的东西是共同孩子开销和共同销售开销，
主要是一部分做的销售开销除是这样，
有一部分就很好，
法官也知道，
并不是所有的买菜给孩子买辅食，
给孩子买玩具都是有记录的，
法官也知道，
所以大体现在的环境是一般只要生了孩子，
彩礼都退不回去，
但是你也要给法官一个相当于台阶，
为什么怕退不回去呀？
我有一部分是花到孩子身上了吗？
另一部分收入举证虽然证明不了，
但法官他可以自由新政啊，
大家养孩子，
谁不知道有些钱是说不明白的，
谁不知道有些钱是算不明白账的呀。
并不是说你每一笔钱都要有证据，
只是说你要。
给法官一个依据，
这十二万八的彩礼花到哪里去了？
一般情况下生了孩子的彩礼都退不回去，
其他还是着目前没有了吧，
等到对方已经偃旗息鼓了，
对方已经不再寄希望于你退他彩礼，
退他车钱了，
再去谈抚养费的问题，
好啊，
就这样啊，
拜拜，
因为此时此刻男方还是属于一种超强对抗的态度，
因为从男方角度来看的话，
我花钱彩礼钱花了，
买车钱我也花了，
孩子不在我身边，
他觉得他亏了，
所以你现在去跟他谈的话，
他一定是对抗的态度，
谈不出来结果的，
你拖一拖，
拖一拖了之后，
可能一年之后他已经接纳了这个事儿了，
甚至他都已经快要二婚了，
他都已经快要生第二个孩子了，
好在起诉问他要抚养费，
记得点赞关注哦。